what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special and I'm trying to help have a
small impact on your growth with these
videos and so to help you on your
journey today we're continuing the best
of Tony series where we look at some of
the best clips that Tony Robbins has
come up with today's theme is believe I
hope you enjoy think about what's the
Holy Grail between somebody taking
action or not it's one word certainty
when somebody has absolutely certain day
you know the common word is believe
right but you know you can believe in a
general level or you can believe what's
certain when you're absolutely certain
that if I do this it's gonna get that
result and that results gonna change my
life you'll do it when you think it
absolutely is not gonna work you're
never gonna do it the middle no-man's
land of maybe it'll work maybe it won't
that's the piece that kills people
right so if it's a must for you you got
to make it work right in our case right
that's an example it's none of us for
you and you're not sure you don't know
what to do so I years ago I'd look
around and say okay how do people get
themself to follow through they haven't
been following through what's the
difference and I started interviewing
hundreds of people literally and
eventually thousands gonna have
thousands of my vids so I'd ask the
group to give me their feedback they
came up with this model it's like the
holy grail of belief or the holy grail
of Momentum's like the difference
between what makes the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer right and the
difference male knows mindset the like
how's that built so this idea created
stupid little [ __ ] boxes and I'll
scribble it here for it you think about
the first thing that determines whether
you can do something or not and I put
that in this first box at the top here
on the left side it's potential like
what's the potential of the MA
like when you guys started you proved
something no one had done in history
around the four-minute mile right for
godly knows how many centuries they're
trying to run a four-minute mile roger
bannister does it how did he do it
do you remember you did it in this
industry right you made a million bucks
in a day no one had ever done that in
history right now if you did it a bunch
of the guys are doing it because it
became possible roger bannister didn't
just go physically practice he made a
shift in his hat he practiced in his
head because he could never achieve it
physically so he had a change of his
head first so the result became certain
enough he believed it and his body got
him through after
Roger Bannister in that four-minute mile
within two years 37 people ran a
four-minute mile when no one in history
never done here's how it works the
potential for anybody getting your
product is extraordinary they can do
what you've done is much more or less
big do whatever they want to do the
potentials their markets proven that
whether or not they happen the potential
has a lot to do with what action they
take which is the question you Keenan
was right like you know Todd Leon's
potential they're not taking action and
we all know that the action that egg is
gonna determine the results they get
that's pre obvious so most people have a
belief about what their real potential
isn't matter what you tell them and that
affects how much action they take and of
course that affects the result and then
ironically that result reinforces their
belief and then that belief affects it
so I'll give an example let's say a
person has unlimited potential we all
agree but they take little action little
results why because they have to start
with a problem with their belief they
don't believe it's really gonna happen
for me maybe for Frank Kern's cuz it got
the cool hair and stuff or maybe it's
for you because you're so driven but
it's not me maybe Tony Robbins because
she's a freak got these big teeth
whatever their thought process is right
they got this thing right but what
happens is if you believe that there's
very little potential how much action
you're gonna take and when you take a
little potential with a little action
what kind of results you get lousy
little results and we need a little
results what does that do to your belief
you go see I told you this was a waste
of time soldier this wouldn't work and
then what happens you tap even less
potential you take even less actually
even the worst results and your belief
gets even weaker and this sucker feeds
on itself until you are in a downward
spiral poisonous it's poisonous and it's
self-fulfilling
now what if something could happen that
could come along and fill you with a
sense of absolute certainty not like I
believe but me well you know and you
guys this case mine as well we knew
because we had to because we burned the
boats there was no other option we had
to find the way we had we weren't gonna
live that way we all did it in different
ways and for different reasons but in
that sense that was it if you get
yourself in a state of certainty that
this is gonna work I'm gonna find the
way and if this is work I will make the
way then you tap a lot more potential
when you
certain your potential you take massive
action when you take massive action you
really believe in something you get
great results when you get great results
your brain goes see I told you I was a
stud I told you this thing would work
out now you even stronger you tap more
potential take greater action better
results that's how you went from 300
bucks in a week to twenty five hundred
and five days to a hundred thousand and
a month to a million bucks in a day same
thing with you and we get momentum so
we're rich get richer the poor get
poorer now some people go out they go
well I'm gonna take a bunch of action
alright I'm gonna open this product
we're gonna try it and they'll say to
you I even did it but it's like the
salesman who goes and knocks on the door
he knocks on a hundred doors and says
verbally his face says it because he
doesn't believe it's gonna work
so his voice his body the execution is
so weak maybe if he talks a hundred
people somebody's gonna buy on a pity
they don't want his kids to starve right
but he's not gonna get the result so the
core difference in people is how do you
produce certain day when the world isn't
giving it to you you go out and try and
you're trying your case you're a hundred
thousand a debt nothing's working how do
you keep yourself going the way you did
it the way I did it the way you're doing
it we mean I've done it consciously is
we didn't change our potential that was
there and it wasn't even taking more
action taking more action with beliefs
not gonna works not gonna change
anything we got results in our head that
made us feel certain as if it had
already happened
true or false for you true alright so
give me an example some people know I'm
not just making this crap up well I mean
just like when I had nothing I already
knew I was driving like Ferraris and
Porsches and stuff because I always
wanted those cars I already knew I was
going to have them it was inevitable
right I never you know that was just my
inevitable outcome but how did you do
that did you have a ritual did you think
about it regularly was it one kind of
you thought about it or was it something
you had an obsession towards I had an
obsession towards it I mean I used to go
I weren't used to work in a video store
which is the last job I ever had in my
life thank God and I used to go to work
almost every day and I used to bring two
magazines with me to read on my breaks
entrepreneur magazine just to read about
business and everything else to read
about what other people are doing look
for role models and I used to carry an
auto trader with me and I used to look
at Porsches that were for sale yeah and
people always used to ask me what are
you doing with that auto trader magazine
I'm like well I'm just picking out the
Porsche that I'm going to buy
when I'm which probably got you a lot of
crap people made fun of me I actually
had a boss at that job tell me you know
you really shouldn't do that to yourself
John because it's it's very very likely
that that is never gonna happen that
it's very likely that you you're never
going to have that car yeah that's
that's the kind of belief he was trying
to put in my head and I was like no you
don't realize that it's it's inevitable
that I will drive here it's sometime in
the near future with that car when I'm
not working for you and drop movies off
for you to put back on the shelf and
anybody who wants to succeed is God and
no it doesn't just happen you can buy a
product but you also with that product
have got to condition yourself you got
to make it a must thing you got to get a
ritual if you do it whatever you used to
dream about you thought was so huge
you'll just live it you'll live it like
you live this yesterday like we're all
living the life that we envisioned
because we had to and because we played
this game with our head we got the
belief to be real by seeing it enough
times and feel it enough times to our
brain believed it and then it made it
happen which raised the potential which
made us take more action which got us
better results which raised our beliefs
again that's right rich get richer and
the poor get poorer so instead of
bitching about it change it this process
is the Holy Grail
it's where the whole game changes and
anybody can do it and they can do it in
a few minutes and if they do it a few
minutes each day then they get a
different life they do it a few minute
one time their life changes for the day
it's we're defined by our rituals
everybody's got rituals certain things
they do every day and what we have in
common and anybody that I know of who
has a life that they're living that was
once a vision is we saw it again and
again again even when it didn't work
even when you lost the hunter grant you
working as a janitor there was something
we would not give up on if somebody
watching want to change their life they
got aside what they won't give up on and
then put themselves in the stay that
momentum by a couple little rituals
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of Tony's message it's one
that I obviously agree with in that it's
believed but I'd love to hear what you
guys have to say what did you learn from
this video please let me know leave it
down in the comments below I'm looking
forward to hearing what you have to say
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love
see you soon